hi I'm Emma Carmichael and welcome to a
video edition of ask Evan today I'm
going to answer a question from one of
my readers max Max's question is hey
Evan I was taking a look at the tools
you use and was wondering what program
you used to create your homepage that
you look for the Internet you show a pic
but don't tell how you did it if it
requires programming
I might need my programming to do it for
me but if I could do it myself that
would be best
max so what max is talking about on my
website I have a list of my favorite
tools and these are a lot of the tools
that I use does help save me time and
really help grow my business without
having to add a lot of manpower
underneath if you scroll down you'll see
a lot of different tools that I like to
use and under this section here running
your business
I recommend save time by creating the
home page dashboard I've also included a
full picture so you kind of see a little
bit better on my Facebook page and this
shows you all the different tools that I
use on a regular basis and it saves time
by having it all in one spot so that I
can have access to everything quickly as
I click through on my website so these
are the most popular websites that I use
on a day-to-day basis to run my business
some of them you can see are personal
some of them I key suppliers business
and then the social media stuff that I'm
involved in as well
so what I'm gonna do is show you if I
load a new tab go to home this is what's
gonna load every time I load up a new
browser I'm gonna show you two quick
ways to do it
one is how I actually do it and I'm
going to also show you an easier method
if you're not as technically savvy here
we go
[Music]
okay so the first method I'm going to
show you is what I actually use to
create my homepage dashboard I use a
program called Dreamweaver and it's a
pretty common program that you can use
to make really advanced websites but
it's also great for beginners as well so
this is what it looks like I'll click on
my homepage and editing it is almost
like adding a word document if you know
how to do word you can get started with
Dreamweaver so say I want to add
something to my homepage and maybe under
personal I will add in Toronto dance
salsa which is where I do a lot of salsa
dancing I can either add a text link
like this I've done that a couple times
here well I'll do that if I'm feeling
lazy or I could try to go out and find a
picture that would make sense for that
website so say for this one I want to
find the logo for Toronto dine salsa I
can go to Google Images google.com slash
images and I'll type in Toronto dance
salsa and here is the logo so I'll click
on that I will save the picture and I'll
call it Toronto dance salsa Inc
[Music]
there we go I will go back to my
dreamweaver I'll make a new line and
then I'll go insert image and let's find
it on the dance salsa okay and there it
is so I can either make a text link here
or the picture link as well now we need
to actually go get the link so the link
is here's the website I'll copy and
paste the link go back to my Dreamweaver
I'll highlight the image and where it
says link I'll just copy and paste that
in and if I want over the text I'll also
put the link here now for pictures
you'll see that blue borders come around
that I tend to find them a little ugly
so all I'll do is click 0 for border and
it gets rid of my border I will save it
and then if I go back load my web
browser if I click home you'll see that
now I've added my image and my text link
to Toronto dance salsa and if I click on
it
there I am
[Music]
so once you've gone through the step of
adding all the different pictures and
text links that you want in to run your
business we have to save the file
properly to do that you just go file
save as and then you name the file
whatever I created a new folder on my
computer called home page and then I
called it home page you can be more
creative if you like but that's what I
did for my own site then you'll see that
as a file that's run off of my own
computer so this isn't anywhere else on
the web for other people to use it's
just stored on my computer and here's
the exact route so this will change
depending on wherever you want to save
it but it's going to be on your own
computer then when I load up my internet
browser I'm using Chrome in this example
but all the different internet browsers
will have an option from here I'm just
gonna click in one of my options and
it'll say home page open this page and
you can give it the URL so this is now
gonna call my new dashboard home page
whenever I load up a new browser you can
see if I can home there it is so if
you're using Chrome Firefox or Internet
Explorer or any of the different
browsers they all have an option to set
your default home page and you want to
make that your local file so you can see
here this is the same extension name
that I used when I saved it through
Dreamweaver
[Music]
okay so I promised you another way to do
it if you don't have Dreamweaver or you
don't want to invest the time into
learning it and it's simple and it's
through notepad so this is really
bare-bones you have to know a little bit
of HTML but it's not that complicated so
what I'm going to do here just to show
you I'm gonna create a new file I loaded
up my notepad and I'll call it evans
pool resources and if I want to make it
bigger I'll just put a h1 in front of it
and I'll close the h1 tag at the end of
it and if I want to link to Toronto
dance also as an example it's important
to know that if you're gonna create a
link it's a her F equals the link
Toronto dance also dossier then you put
in the text that you want to actually
show up so try to a dance salsa and then
close close that off okay so this page
is only going to say open school
resources with the h1 so will be bigger
and in regular font will show the link
to the site okay so it's very bare-bones
I can go save as and I'm gonna put it in
the same folder so home page and I'm
gonna call it home page two and here is
important you want to call it dot HTM
instead of dot txt which is the default
so save a dot HTM okay and it's been
saved now if I go to my internet browser
I should be able to click here and put
the two at the end of it and here's my
site
so Evan school resources trying to dance
salsa and if I click on it that will now
work if I wanted to add the picture in
instead of this text here a quick way is
go image' SRC for source equals put it
in quotes and close that off and then we
have to go find the picture again so if
I just quickly load up my Google Images
calm images fine Toronto dance salsa
find that logo I'm gonna copy the image
URL and as I go back into my notepad I'm
gonna paste it in here and now I'm gonna
save it again safe then if I go back to
here i refresh this page you see this a
picture and if I load that there is
website so you can keep going on and add
more links and more pictures until
you've made it to your satisfaction and
you got a cool list of tools that use on
a regular basis to help save you some
time if I wanted to then set this page
is my default I would copy that link I
would go back to my options and then I
would here paste the link and yeah then
the next time I load my browser this new
page will load instead of the existing
one so hopefully this is an easy way for
you to be able to create your own home
page and if you have any other questions
I'd be happy to answer them
thank you for joining me for another
edition of ask Evan if you liked the
video please give it a thumbs up I'd
also love to hear your thoughts and
feedback below if you want to leave a
comment and stay tuned for the next
episode
[Music]